despite all of their charges collapsing
Democrats plan to move forward with two
articles of impeachment against
President Trump we will examine why it's
all happening now how did we get to the
point where we can't agree on anything
some people blame President Trump some
blame the IG report which just came out
some are blaming a weak Democratic field
and boy is it weak the real root cause
is far deeper than that we will examine
how this rot has been building since the
80s at least and we will chart a path
forward for how we can all get along
then Walmart apologizes for a coked-out
Santa Clause and so much more I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Noel's show
[Music]
even Santa Claus needs a mountain of
narcotics that is how tense everybody is
right now and Walmart is apologizing for
it we will get to all of that in a
second first amidst all of this
craziness all of this peril and danger
you need to feel safe and I know just
how you can feel safe with ring this
season can be a whirlwind of deliveries
visitors holiday travel it is the best
time of the year to upgrade your
doorbell and keep an eye on your home no
matter where the holidays take you ring
helps you stay connected to your home
from anywhere that means if you're in
your bedroom like my senior producer
Jonathan hay was the other day and some
wackos tried to come in to his house and
he could see hear and speak to them
right from his bed or maybe here at the
office or maybe you're on a beach
somewhere you can see here and speak to
everybody whether that's a package
delivery or a surprise visitor like your
mother-in-law so if it's the Amazon guy
you say okay yeah leave it over there if
it's your mother-in-law you stay
perfectly still hopefully she won't know
that you are there you can check in
anytime you can get some much-needed
holiday peace of mind I really love it I
feel super safe with ring sweet little
Elise is a good shot but better to be
safe than sorry by the way if the
burglar tries to steal your ring
doorbell it uploads it straight to the
cloud so you can see that video already
as a listener you have a special holiday
offer on a ring starter kit available
right now with a ring video doorbell too
and motion-activated floodlight camera
the starter kit has everything you need
to start building a ring of security
around your home with ring you're always
home go to ring.com
forward slash Knowles you're gonna love
it you'll feel like you're in the
Jetsons most importantly you'll feel
very safe ring calm / Knowles keno wles
additional terms may apply so they're
gonna do it the Democrats are going to
do it they're going to impeach Trump
this is breaking news just happening the
Demery knits breaking news except we
could have predicted it three months ago
but it's still it's breaking news
technically the Democrats are gonna file
two articles of impeachment against
President Trump
there's the shallow political story here
which is about the impeachment there is
the broader political context which is
the IG report we'll get to that
the week Democratic presidential field
and then there's the 30,000 foot view
context of why this is all happening now
and I think this is the most important
part I think this has everything to do
with the kind of disagreements you're
seeing on the right right now I mean for
the last three days
conservative Twitter has been arguing
about porn for some reason why it
actually has to do with this why is our
country so divided why are we impeaching
this president it all has to do with the
central problem that has been building
now for at least three four decades we
will get to that let's get to the
breaking news first Democrats are now
officially filing articles of
impeachment against President Trump two
articles the articles are for
obstructing Congress and abuse of power
you can look through the Constitution
say where's that as an impeachable
offense probably not going to find it
they were gonna file a third the third
article was supposed to be for bribery
what would bribery be that was going to
be the actual crime that they were
committing error accusing Trump of
committing the quid pro quo right
he's bribing Ukraine with the military
aid and in exchange for that he's
getting an investigation into his
political rival Joe Biden that was the
whole point of these impeachment
hearings there was the whole point of
the inquiry it's the whole point of the
impeachment and they're abandoning that
because there's no evidence of that
tells you everything you need to know
about this partisan ridiculous farcical
impeachment so they won't be filing the
bribery charge
you only get abuse of Congress and
obstructing or obstructing Congress and
abuse of power how did those hold up on
obstructing Congress they're saying
Trump obstructed Congress by not letting
the executive branch employees testify
okay Trump did have a number of
executive branch employees testified
didn't me he did none of them provided
any evidence that Trump committed the
crime that they're accusing him of which
is bribery which is the quid pro quo how
do we know that because the Democrats
aren't filing the charge for quid pro
quo and actually Gordon Sunland who is
the only guy to actually talk about
Trump's dealings with Ukraine repeatedly
said that
requested no quid pro quo in those exact
words said what do you want Trump said I
want nothing I want no quid pro quo tell
Ukraine to do the right thing so they
don't have that the second charge abuse
of power abuse of power is not an
impeachable offense Alan Dershowitz who
we have on the show sometimes we have
him on the radio show sometimes Alan
Dershowitz great law professor
repeatedly points out this is not an
impeachable offense it might be
inappropriate it might be deserving of
censure let's say but it is not an
impeachable offense now there was an
another charge that the Democrats were
considering adding a far left
representative Pramila jayapal suggested
adding the charge of obstruction of
justice different than obstructing
Congress they are saying he obstructed
Congress because he didn't send all of
his people to go testify obstructing
justice
they were considering adding because
Trump went to the courts to push back
against this impeachment farce going to
the courts going to the third co-equal
branch of government is not obstruction
of justice if anything that is pursuing
justice and not allowing the legislature
to run roughshod over the executive so
Nancy Pelosi came to her senses there
they're not going to file that they have
these two very weak arguments as we've
just shown those those two charges fall
completely flat which means that in
their actual public testimony Democrats
are reverting to their former argument
the only actual impeachment argument
that they have ever been making
consistently that argument is three
words long orange man bad here is the
Democratic Council Barry Burke making
this argument in explicit terms before I
had the great honor of being a counsel
for this committee my young son asked me
a question he said dad does the
president have to be a good person like
many questions by young children it had
a certain clarity but it was hard to
answer I said son
it is not a requirement that the
president be a good person but that is
the hope and it is not a requirement
that the president be a good person
that is not why we are here today that
is not the issue
all right see you guys I think I'm gonna
leave I think I'm not gonna leave just
the studio or the Daily wire I think I'm
gonna leave the country because
obviously this experiment in
self-government that we've had is over
when you when you were trying to
overturn a presidential election when
you were trying to impeach the president
and for the first time in history try to
remove him from office through the
process of impeachment because your son
wonders if he's not a good person that's
it I guess we're over right that's it we
might be we we might be past the point
of self-government we'll get to why a
little bit later in the show this is
pathetic
this is absolutely pathetic if the
Democrats had not backed themselves into
a corner what they could have done here
is had the hearings figured out to
everybody who's paying attention that
Trump did not commit an impeachable
offense and then censured him anyway so
then the Congress votes to censure him
and they can take this as at least a
slight political victory but they backed
themselves too far into a corner and
their base is demanding removal from
office because as Democratic
Representative Al Green says they fear
that if they don't impeach this
president he will be re-elected they
fear the American people they fear that
he's actually doing good things and he's
fairly popular and so they've got to
remove him from office extra
constitutionally or else who's going to
get reelected they don't have any actual
charge against him so it's the
Democratic Council talking to his little
boy saying gosh the president's a bad
man and let me look article two I don't
know section 5 or 6 or 7 there's got to
be some section here where you can
remove the president for being a meanie
for being a really bad guy absolutely
pathetic representative Doug Collins the
Republican who actually was a star
yesterday at the impeachment hearings
Doug Collins said what we're all
thinking that this is a farce that there
is no impeachable offense what would be
known about this one is
probably where's the impeachable offense
why are we here I tell you this maybe
though become known as the focus group
impeachment because we don't have a
crime we don't have anything we can
actually pin and nobody understands
really what the majority is trying to do
except they interfere and basically make
sure that they believe the president
can't win next year if he's impeached
the focus-group impeachment takes words
and then takes them to people and say
how can we explain this better because
we don't have the facts to match it a
focus group impeachment says you know we
really aren't working with good facts
but we need a good PR move that's why
we're here today the point he's making
is completely right this is the
focus-group impeachment right they've
tried to impeach him now for three years
for different reasons the only thing
that stayed the same the only thing
that's been consistent is the fact that
they want to impeach him but initially
it was colluding with Russia then it was
stormy Daniels then it was his taxes
then it was colluding with Ukraine now
it's not even that it's not even a crime
committed with Ukraine it's a crime
committed or not a crime but an abuse
committed while he was being impeached
obstructing Congress now it's abuse of
power whatever that means it's actually
changed again were actually past Ukraine
all that's been consistent is that they
want to impeach the guy I like that the
point that he's making that this is
being focused grouped on the reasoning
the conclusion always being the same
it's a little bit of a weak talking
point and no one's going to refer to the
focus group impeachment it's one of
those things that sounds really good to
people in DC the American people don't
register with that too much that doesn't
resonate with them I think probably the
better term that resonates with them is
the term Trump has been using which is
that it's a BS impeachment I think we
can all identify with that but
absolutely Collins's point stands he
then starts drilling down on these
Democratic councils he he exposed the
greatest irony of the whole impeachment
scam which is that the only person to
commit the offense that Democrats were
initially at least accusing Trump of is
not Trump not some
who worked for Trump not another
Republican it's Joe Biden he gets
Collins gets the Democratic Council
Daniel Goldman to admit that the only
person to commit a quid pro quo here
with Ukraine is Joe Biden as I remember
going over to the Ukraine convincing our
team our leaders convincing them that we
should provide for loan guarantees so I
went over I guess the 12th or 13th time
to give I suppose to announce that there
was a billion dollar loan guarantee and
I gotten a commitment from poroshenko
and their scent that I would take action
against that they would take action
against a prosecutor they didn't so they
said so they said they had they were
walking out to the press conference I
said now I'm not going to or we're not
going to give you the billion dollars
they said you have authority you have no
authority you're not the president the
president said I said call him laughter
I said I'm telling you you're getting
you're not getting the billion dollars I
said you're not getting the billion
dollars I'm getting me I'm getting
getting ready to be leaving here and I
think about six hours I looked at them
and said I'm leaving here in six hours
if the prosecutor is not fired you're
not getting the money well son of a
[ __ ] she got fired did he ask for
something request something at holds
something of value he did George Kent
testified that that I think I'll do what
you did George Kent test I'm asking
about not George Kent I'm asking about
this it's important cannot answer this
question did he or did he not easy
either Joe Biden's a liar telling a
story to make people impressed or he
actually did this which isn't he did it
pursuant to US official policy so he did
it in holding withholding actual dollars
actual thing holding this out there so
Joe Biden of everybody that we discussed
but is the only one that's done a quid
pro quo he's the only one to see use
taxpayer dollars to actually threaten a
foreign government and yet we're sitting
here pretending that this is not
happening
thank you Thank You representative
Collins for saying the most obvious
point about the whole impeachment
hearing that were initially at least
going after Trump for a quid pro quo
that he didn't commit
when if he did commit a quid pro quo it
was only to investigate the quid pro quo
that we know for a fact Joe Biden
committed because he admitted it thank
you thank you very much not that it
matters because nobody cares about
actual facts of this because we are dug
into our partisanship because of this
root problem that we've had now for a
few decades which we will get to but it
just shows you the absurdity the
hypocrisy of the whole hearing he digs
in and Daniel Goldman is a partisan
Democrat okay he's obviously is the
Democratic counsel he's a partisan
Democrat Mary Burke who's the other
Democratic counsel
he's a partisan Democrat too I don't
begrudge them their partisanship that's
fine it's worth pointing out that the
expert witness that the Republicans
called on their behalf was John Jonathan
Turley who's actually a liberal who
actually voted against President Trump
who in so much as you can be nonpartisan
here is definitely not partisan with the
Republicans Democrats are just doubling
down on their guys that's fine
you then have after Doug Collins just
knocks down this whole impeachment
nonsense you then have Matt gates
congressman Brad gates come in for the
kill and expose the rank partisanship
all around the Democratic circus
are you a partisan I am NOT a partisan
mr. Kaster how long you worked for the
House since 2005 and the same question
school for the house since earlier this
year mr. Castro do you make political
donations I don't remember any uh mr.
Goldman same question do you make
political donations I do sir I think
it's very important fact afford you've
given tens of thousands of dollars to
Democrats right sir I think it's very
important to support candidates for
office I think mr. Castro have you ever
tweeted anything at the president yeah
mr. Goldman same question I have made a
number of tweets in my private capacity
before I came to this job when I was
working in the media yes matter of fact
this is one of those tweets right oh did
you read my Twitter account oh now you
looked into my political donations and
my Twitter account so he points out the
Daniel Goldman's given tens of thousands
of dollars to Democrats and Barry Burke
the other Democrat Council has given
over one hundred thousand dollars so
what this is all about is partisanship
of course it's partisan what's offensive
to all of us is when Daniel Goldman says
I'm not a partisan
this is not a partisan impeachment Nancy
Pelosi says this has nothing to do with
politics oh yeah well if it didn't have
anything to do with politics maybe you
would have found a crime maybe you would
have found an impeachable offense but
you didn't so this is a strictly
political maneuver fine the whole thing
is about defending Democrats on two
fronts it's about defending Democrats
against an investigation into the Russia
investigation we just got the first part
of that investigation the IG report and
it's about defending Democrats from
their own weak presidential field
speaking of the ladder let's check in
with Democratic frontrunner Joe Biden
okay yep things going bad as well as the
last time we checked in on Joe Biden so
that's not great and he's the leader of
the pack for now there's a new poll out
from Harvard Harris showing the top five
2020 Democratic presidential candidates
among voters right now it's Biden and
29% Sanders at 16 Warren at 13 who to
judge at 8 and Bloomberg at 7 good on
Bloomberg he's really rising up in the
world in me probably not gonna go
anywhere but still you know he's doing
doing better than some of the other
lower to your candidates that's the
Harvard Harris Poll as it stands right
now the minute that you add people like
Hillary Clinton and John Kerry into the
race Biden completely collapses
so if you add Hillary Clinton and John
Kerry you now get the front-runner as
Hillary Clinton with 21% Joe Biden with
twenty Sanders at 12 Warren at nine
Budaj and Kerry at five the multi time
loser
one of the most reviled women in America
Hillary Clinton is currently leading the
pack of Democratic presidential
candidates and she's not even running
this is a bad situation for Democrats to
be and so what are they doing the
impeachment is important to distract
from this bad pack of care
it's this now the theater here the
theater helps president Trump right
because they're distracting from the
candidates with impeachment trouble as
the impeachment is helping him quarterly
polling by the Republican firm fire has
strategies has President Trump
struggling or it had president Trump
struggling in Michigan Pennsylvania and
Wisconsin those are all the
battlegrounds those states are very
likely to determine the 2020 election he
was struggling right until the latest
poll until the poll that came out after
impeachment had started in which he
beats every single Democratic candidate
nothing could be better for Trump than
this impeachment you know Lindsey Graham
on the Judiciary Committee is saying
that once the house impeaches and it
goes to trial in the Senate they're
gonna get this impeachment over with
ASAP
no do not do that drag this thin out
that's a terrible idea
this is so helpful to Trump this should
drag on for two months now I think what
Lindsey Graham is thinking what
Republicans on the hill are thinking is
we need to wrap this up because we've
already won impeachment has helped us
let's just get it over with before
something bad happens what could happen
you could call Joe Biden to testify and
he could start crying and show himself
to be a sympathetic witness and turn the
impeachment in his favor
you could get hunter Biden to testify a
complete degenerate but he could still
invoke some sympathy the Biden's are
very good at this okay fine
don't get them to testify I don't think
you need to get either of those guys to
testify just keep dragging out all these
Democratic lawyers who are so awful
Pamela Carlin Daniel Goldman Noah
Feldman all these guys that are just so
unlikable and so elitist and so
disconnected from the American people
that is how you drag out Adam Schiff get
Adam Schiff to testify before the Senate
drag out Associates of the Biden's I
don't know drag out hunter Biden's coke
dealer who knows drag that out for a
long time that really helps Trump it
drills the point home the Democrats have
nothing and the Democrats will pretend
to have something even when they've got
nothing right so the thing is if you
wrap up impeachment right now the
Democrats are going to declare a victory
even though they've
every single stage of this so you've got
to keep showing the American people that
the Democrats have nothing otherwise the
mainstream media aren't going to do it
for you a great example of this is the
IG report the IG report just came out
here's ABC News's take after user
president Trump calling it a deep state
saying the FBI was anti-trump when it
launched an investigation into possible
ties between his campaign and Russia
tonight the long-awaited independent
report the Justice Department's
inspector general revealing there was no
evidence of a witch hunt determining the
FBI had enough evidence pointing to
either a federal crime or threat to
national security or both to justify the
probe at the height of the election and
that the agents who made the final
decision to launch the investigation
were not influenced by political by oh
okay so no witch-hunt
the FBI totally fine Democrats good
orange man bad okay now I get it except
of course that's not that's not really
what happened the IG reports that mean
IG report is extremely long so you can
read the executive summary or something
it said that the FBI committed a whole
slew of errors in the lead up to
wiretapping and spying on the Trump
campaign
now ultimately the IG said this wasn't
some politically motivated conspiracy it
was just incompetence and a number of
mistakes so spying on the Trump campaign
spying on quarter-page there was a
flawed but not improperly motivated what
what does the IG report say 17 quote
serious performance failures relating to
warrants obtained by the FBI through the
FISA courts the Foreign Intelligence
Surveillance Amendment courts on the the
spying on quarter-page spying on the
Trump campaign that FISA warrant was
reauthorized three times it contained
false and misleading information about
Paige repeatedly it failed to disclose
the fact that Paige had had already
disclosed his Russian contacts to a
government agency pretended that he
hadn't it overstated the government's
confidence in the steal dossier and it
also ignored Christopher Steele's own
doubts about his own
dossier and it never mentioned the page
and mana for Paul Manafort the former
chairman of the Trump campaign had quote
literally never met okay that's a lot of
errors isn't it it's a lot so you're
just saying okay the FBI yeah they made
some mistakes but there's no problem of
motivation here that's a little hard for
me to believe here's President Trump
stick okay thank you very much the IG
report just came out and I was just
briefed on it and it's a disgrace what
has happened with respect to the things
that were done to our country and should
never again happen to another president
it is incredible far worse than I would
have ever thought possible and it's it's
an embarrassment to our country it's
dishonest it's it's everything that a
lot of people thought it would be except
far worse so I'm going to get some very
detailed briefing but briefings but they
they are it's a very sad it's a very sad
day when I see that for sad day when a
lot of people see that
okay classic Trump answer it's the worst
thing I've ever seen it couldn't
possibly be worse it's terrible I happen
to agree with him on the main points
here I think it's really really bad the
trouble is that the conclusions of the
IG reports were too weak they were too
moderate they gave too much deference to
the bureaucrats and so Trump is kind of
underplaying that he's pointing to the
actual facts of the investigation
I think Lindsey Graham had the most
nuanced and accurate take on this which
is the the flaws of the investigation
itself the the actual facts that the IG
found that is what is disturbing and
that merits further investigation I
believe there will be no debate among
reasonable minded people particularly
lawyers about how the system not only
got off the rails but in my view became
a criminal enterprise to defraud the
FISA Court to deny American citizen
Carter pages constitutional rights and
to continue an operation against
Trump as president United States I think
was fundamentally flawed and unlawful
even if the initial process of spying on
the Trump campaign even if we're gonna
grant the benefit of the doubt to these
bureaucrats certainly after the
beginning after the middle in the late
stages of this this had become something
far far worse than a simple mistake
you don't repeatedly lie to the FISA
courts you don't repeatedly omit
relevant information
you don't repeatedly lean on a source
who is being paid by the Hillary Clinton
campaign unless there's something more
going on here when you add to that all
of the text messages we saw between
Peters struck and Lisa page when you add
to that the meetings that were alleged
to have happened in Andy McCabe's office
when you add to that everything we
already know this thing stinks to high
heaven and beyond
Trump's take beyond Graham's take you
get the Attorney General William bar who
importantly disagreed with the
conclusions of the IG report Barr said
quote the inspector general's report now
makes clear that the FBI launched an
intrusive investigation of a u.s.
presidential campaign on the thinnest of
suspicions in my view that in my view
were insufficient to justify the steps
taken so the IG says they were
sufficient to take the steps that they
did to spy on the Trump campaign Barra
says no they didn't bar goes on FBI
officials mislead the FISA Court emitted
critical exculpatory facts from their
filings and suppress or ignored
information negating the reliability of
their principal source absolutely right
John Durham who is the investigator the
the US attorney appointed by Bill Barr
months ago to also investigate this
matter and at the time we thought wait a
second you've already got the IG why are
you appointing John Durham it's because
obviously the AG William bard knew at
that time that the IG was not going to
take this to its logical conclusion so
he was employed ting another
investigator to pursue a criminal
investigation on the matter John Durham
said more or less the same thing he said
it even a little tougher last month we
advised the Inspector General
that we do not agree with some of the
reports conclusions as to predication
and how the FBI case was opened now the
big question we have how does this all
relate to internet porn sort of I'm I'm
actually not totally kidding here we
have been having lots of cultural
debates on the right about the the
nature of what we believe what we want
for America how we can conserve the
American nation how we should relate to
libertarianism and traditionalism and
it's actually all the same conversation
the big question is why why is this all
happening now why are we re litigating
the 2016 election why are we impeaching
the president over nothing
why is the bureaucracy trying to
overturn the will of the American people
why are we arguing about porn why are we
arguing about all these things the
problem is we have nothing in common and
this was because of a deal made between
the right and the left decades ago that
has not given us very good fruit we'll
get to that in a second first I've got
to say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube
and listen up my friends because I am
going to save you time and money for
your Christmas shopping the perfect gift
for your loved ones you know what it is
it's a daily wire gifts membership from
now til January 1st all insider plus
gift memberships will be 25% off that
means that your loved one will get all
the fantastic perks plus the beautiful
majestic leftist ears tumblr and you
will get all the savings that's a good
deal go to daily wired.com slash gift to
get your twenty five percent off again
that's daily wire.com slash gift to get
your twenty five percent off twenty five
percent off all insider plus gift
memberships of this holiday season give
them a gift they will thank you for all
year long plus you can get other cool
merchandise like all of our sweet daily
wired shirts go to daily wire com we
will be right back
why are we still litigating the 2016
election why why are Democrats
impeaching a president for nothing why
did the FBI try to rig an election why
because we have very little in common
that's why the big the big argument on
the right in recent months has been
between the traditionalists and the
libertarians okay the between the show
robberies and the David French's between
the people who want to ban porn and the
people who want there to be pouring all
over the place even if they don't like
it they want everyone to have the
opportunity to see it it's between the
people who say that the ultimate aim of
politics is a good Society and the
people who say that the ultimate pursuit
of politics is leave me alone
libertarian individual freedom though
that's the debate that's going on right
now how did we get here which way should
we lean from the 80s to the present
there has been this strange left-right
consensus there's actually been
something of a consensus an alliance
between left-wing liberals who want to
be left alone on social issues and
between right-wing liberals I say
liberal in the kind of classical sense
of that word who want to be left alone
with their money so yet the left-wing
liberals who say don't bother me about
sex or culture or the arts or my body or
any of that's just don't leave me alone
with that and then the right says okay
we'll leave you alone on that if you
leave us alone on our money let us keep
all of our money and the left doesn't
usually go along with that but that's
that's the rough alliance that they've
made we're seeing the fruit of that
alliance now we can't agree on what
marriages we can't agree on what life is
or when it begins we can't agree on what
the government should be or look like or
is we can't agree on what a man is we
can't agree on what a woman is we can't
even agree on what language to speak
it's now a controversial conservative
opinion to say that we should speak
English in America
often you'll call a customer service
line and you'll you'll hear for English
press one and you'll hear something in
Spanish that maybe you can't understand
it's now considered bigoted in some
quarters to say that the official
language of America should be English
that's how little we agree on we can't
even agree on the language that we
should speak to talk about whether we
agree on things that is the fruit of
leave me alone I have nothing to do with
you that's the fruit of hyper
individualism on the social side when it
comes to the left and on the money side
when it comes to the right I'm a huge
fan of lower taxes I don't think we
should pay higher taxes I don't think we
should have more government regulations
coming in and taking my property but the
reason for that is economic freedom is a
good way to pursue a good country a good
society a good place to live it's not an
end in and of itself maximal individual
autonomy is not an end in and of itself
the end that that allows for is virtue
is a good life is good healthy
communities is a good country that's
what we've got to agree to I think the
whole leave-me-alone politics oh come on
who cares it's not a big deal you can
have your weird creepy sex stuff and we
can keep all of our money and never the
twain shall meet
that is a losing proposition because
eventually if Andrew Breitbart is
correct the politics is down stream of
culture and if also politics affects
culture ultimately you are going to have
a country that's so separated that we're
going to come to heads we're going to
come to conflict that is what is
happening right now if we were a country
the kind of understood one another that
we had a basically similar sense of the
common good the highest good similar
kind of sense of culture similar kind of
sense of religion I'm not saying
identical I'm not saying we need some
totally uniform prudish country I'm not
saying we need to be prude in any way
just saying we have to kind of agree on
what we're all about if you had that the
you wouldn't have a bogus impeachment
over nothing you wouldn't you then at
least to come up with some shred of a
crime wouldn't they you wouldn't have
the bureaucracy trying to attack the
people you wouldn't have these separate
languages where half of the country
thinks that the other half of the
country are Nazis are literal Nazis are
bigoted awful terrible deplorable
irredeemable people like Hillary Clinton
said you wouldn't have that because we
would at least I'm not saying we could
agree on everything but we would at
least understand one another we would
have a general sense of where we're all
going what we all want that doesn't
happen that's the fruit of hyper
SuperDuper individualism if we are going
to come back together the answer is not
to go to the lowest common denominator
and say fine I'm not going to ever tell
you anything that you should do and
please you don't tell me anything that I
should do that's not the answer the
answer is we need to actually engage
with one another we do have to say there
is a good there is something we should
be doing there is propriety there is a
definition of a man there is a
definition of marriage there is a
definition of human life that's what
we're gonna have to do that takes a
little courage that takes a little bit
of virtue unfortunately we've so
whittled away at that over the past
several decades that it's hard to even
gather that language that is the task
before us and it's not an easy one and
it's not going to be terribly pleasant
and it might look like there's more
conflict in the short term in the long
run that's the only way that we are
going to have a peaceable society again
it's the only way that we're gonna have
a society based on reason based on
persuasion and that's the only way that
self-government persists now let's get
to an important issue like a coked-up
Santa Clause
Walmart has issued an apology for a
third party item that was listed for
sale on its Canadian website the item is
a sweater with the divide the design
rather of a Santa not wearing pants
sitting on top of a couch or a bed with
a bunch of like a little snowflake
Christmas tree on one side and then
lines of coke on the other and the shirt
says let it snow
Walmart issued this big apology they're
so sorry that they've got this shirt
here it's so terrible thing
the children think of the children come
on guys
it's a funny shirt let it go it's not a
big deal you know so many people as
we've been having these kind of
traditionalist debates over porn and all
that kind of stuff they've said you
conservatives are prude the reason that
I don't like porn is not because I'm
totally scandalized by sexual images or
by you know sort of inappropriate images
it's because it has a bad effect on the
individual and on society and there's
nothing good about it
that's not parishioners I don't think
that we should get rid of shirts that
have Samet blowing coke it's just a
funny joke I mean in this was that a
song I get a kick out of you classic
American Songbook song it says I get a
kick out of you I get no thrill from
cocaine rather people have talked about
coke made jokes about coke certain about
coke alright I'm not saying you should
ever do cocaine I'm just saying you can
have a shirt that makes a joke about
cocaine looking like snow with Santa
Claus that's fine prudishness is not the
answer
the own that what the only criticism
that I will make of this sweatshirt is
that there these sweaters are kind of
lame the idea of the ugly Christmas
sweater that's really subversive and
that's really telling a naughty joke
that has now become lame because that's
all you ever see now in stores are these
like fake Christmas sweaters I actually
think it would be funnier to just wear a
regular Christmas sweater that would
have that would be more countercultural
that would be more subversive but guys
come on we're so tense we're so upset
about everything now let's say and I
have a little coke all right that's fine
let it let people have a couple laughs
there's also some good news I as we've
had all this bad news on the show I want
to leave on some good news on Monday the
Supreme Court rejected a challenge to a
2017 pro life law in Kentucky that
requires doctors to perform ultrasounds
and play the sound of the baby's
heartbeat two women who were seeking
abortion this is great
Kentucky passes this law they say all
right if you want to get an abortion you
want to kill your child you have to hear
that your child has a heartbeat you have
to see the ultrasound man it's really a
baby the whole law says before you can
have an abortion you have to have all
the information the left hates this the
left doesn't want you to have
information on abortion is the minute
you have information you realize that
the left has been telling you lies about
abortion for decades it's not just a
clump of cells it's not dead
it's not alive it's not not human it's a
human being it's living it's your child
so this goes up to the Supreme Court the
Supreme Court to their credit says no
this is perfectly constitutional you can
absolutely do this is great news and
it's it's driving a lot of people crazy
you know there's this British actress
who I've never seen in anything but
she's got a blue checkmark on Twitter
her name is Jameela Jamil she has been
defending abortion in such a crazy wild
intense way that it makes me think she
doesn't really believe what she's saying
she tweeted out quote receiving
thousands of messages about how I made a
mistake having an abortion seven years
ago and how I must be a miserable person
I am in fact a happy thriving
multi-millionaire madly in love with
free time good sleep and a wonderful
career and life but thanks for checking
it's a little kissy face nobody believes
that nobody really believes what'd she
say she clearly feels some shame some
regret at least at the very least some
uncertainty about her decision to kill
her child and sacrifice her child on the
altar of Mammon and the altar of money
and fame and relaxation and sleep listen
to the trade that she made she said yes
I killed my child but in return for
killing my child I'm happy okay
sceptical of that I'm a multimillionaire
oh you committed an immoral act and were
rewarded with wealth that's never
happened before Wow that's how odd
I'm madly in love okay whatever I have
free time good for you I have good sleep
I have a wonderful career and life this
actually does get to the debate that we
were talking about kind of leave me
alone debate the kind of hyper
individualism debate the kind of I'm not
my brother's keeper debate what the left
wants to do is leave me alone let me
have whatever sex I want let me pursue
my career let me kill my babies what the
right ones and it's at its worst in this
kind of hyper individualist selfish way
is let me keep all my money just let me
have my money you can you can kill your
babies I'm just gonna keep my money
we're all good you look you can live in
fantasy you can pretend that men or
women and women or men and you can
pretend that you're happy whatever
that's fine
doesn't bother me I'm gonna keep my
money that is a bad deal that's a deal
that dooms and Destin's society to have
a bad time to not really get along with
one another Winston Churchill famously
said and Ronald Reagan repeated it in
one of his most famous speeches a time
for choosing the destiny of man is not
measured by material computations when
great forces are on the move in the
world we know that we are spirits not
animals a good life is not measured by
how many millions of dollars you've made
it's not measured by how much free time
you have to do nothing it's not measured
by how much good sleep you were able to
get or how many movies or TV shows you
were able to appear it likewise a good
life is not measured by how much money
you were able to keep free yourself and
you can do wonderful things with money
that you keep for yourself but that's
not the measure of a good life a good
life is not even measured by how many of
your own wins and desires and appetites
you were able to indulge a good life is
determined by how good it was actually
good that is the end of it that's the
aim that's what we're striving for
that's what we should be striving for if
you want to have a good life if you want
to have a happy life
that's it's sort of circular do you want
to have a good life you got to be good
about it
you can't just indulge your appetites
all the time because very often we have
disordered appetites if we want that if
we want to try to rediscover that wisdom
that we knew 40 years ago that Ronald
Reagan knew that Winston Churchill knew
that everybody knew
up until now except for us because we
have so degraded our culture if we want
to recover that then we have to start
having conversations not merely about
equality not merely about social justice
not merely about material wealth not
merely about Liberty not even nearly
about this hyper individual liberty but
rather what what Edmund Burke the great
conservative philosopher talks about as
the spirit of an exalted freedom we have
to talk about the good that is going to
be a difficult conversation and I don't
know that we're gonna have a very good
time doing it but we can try that's our
show I'm Michel Knowles this is the
Michael Mel show come back tomorrow I'll
see that the Michael Noel's show is
produced by Rebecca dabka wits and
directed by Mike joiner executive
producer Jeremy boar
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel white
house key
edited by Danny D'Amico audio is mixed
by Mike or Amina hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera
and our production assistant is Nick
Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright day Lee
Weyer 2019 hey everybody its Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the American Republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon is turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew cliff
[Music]